THEY WILL JOIN US FOR EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEWS AND SO MUCH MORE YOU
DON'T WANT TO MISS.
IT'S COMING UP TONIGHT.
BUT FIRST, BIDEN INCORPORATED
HAS BEEN EXPOSED.
THE CLOUD OF CORRUPTION DARKENS
ABOVE JOE AND THE SHADY FAMILIES
FAMILY BUSINESS DEALINGS AND
WE'RE MORE THAT THE FAKE MEDIA
MOB DOES ELIJAH KNOW ABOUT.
WITH ANY AMERICA WITH A
FUNCTIONING BRAIN, IT COULD NOT
BE ANYMORE OBVIOUS WHAT'S GOING
ON HERE.
THIS FAMILY PROFITED OFF OF HIS
DIPLOMACY IN UKRAINE AND IN
CHINA.
EVEN AS THE MEDIA MOB IS DOING
EVERYTHING IN THEIR POWER TO TRY
TO COVER FOR THEM, AND SUSPEND
ANY FIDELITY TO TRUTH, NOW WE
HAVE OUTLINED ON THE SHOW NIGHT
AFTER NIGHT, JOE AND HIS SONS
ITS SHADY DEALINGS IN UKRAINE
WERE SLEEPY CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE
JOE LEVERAGED YOUR TAX DOLLARS
TO GET A PROSECUTOR FIRED.
WHY WOULD ANY VICE PRESIDENT IN
THE UNITED STATES EVER INVOLVED
HIMSELF IN SUCH A THING?
AS BAD AS JOE WAS BRAGGING ON
TAPE IS, THAT WAS JUST MERE
MILLIONS.
THAT'S ALL.
BUT THE BIGGER, THE MUCH
BRIGHTER SPOTLIGHT NOW SHINES ON
THE COMMUNIST CHINESE WERE
HUNTER BIDEN RECEIVED A
SWEETHEART BILLION-DOLLAR, LATER
BILLION AND A HALF DOLLAR DEAL
JUST DAYS AFTER TRAVELING WITH
HIS FATHER ON AIR FORCE TWO.
THESE ARE THE FACTS AS WE HAVE
NOW KNOWN THEM.
WE REWIND.
WE GO BACK TO DECEMBER 2013
BRITT HUNTER BIDEN JOINED HIS
FATHER ON AIR FORCE TWO ON A
TRIP TO CHINA WHERE HIS FATHER
HAD A MEETING WITH THE CHINESE
PRESIDENT.
THEN IN DECEMBER, 2013,
LITERALLY LESS THAN TWO WEEKS
LATER, HUNTER BIDEN COMPANY HAD
ABOUT $1 BILLION PRIVATE EQUITY
DEAL WITH A SUBSIDIARY DEAL OF
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT BANK OF
CHINA.
AS PETER SCHWEIZER OUTLINED AND
POINTED OUT IN SECRET EMPIRES,
THE NUMBER ONE BEST SELLER, THIS
WAS A DEAL UNLIKE ANY OTHER
WESTERN FIRM GOD AND IT WENT TO
HUNTER BIDEN WHO AS FAR AS WE
CAN TELL, HAD ZERO EXPERTISE IN
CHINA OR PRIVATE EQUITY.
NOW SCHWEITZER EXPLAINS ENSURE
THAT THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT WAS
LITERALLY FUNDING A BUSINESS
THAT IS COOWNED, ALONG WITH THE
SONS OF TWO OF AMERICA'S MOST
POWERFUL DECISION-MAKERS.
THE BANK OF CHINA, THAT'S NOT
YOUR AVERAGE BANK.
THAT'S NOT LIKE CHASE, CITIBANK,
NO.
IT IS A POWERFUL TOOL CONTROLLED
BY THE COMMUNIST CHINESE, BY
BEIJING.
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO WIELD
TREMENDOUS POLITICAL POWER.
HUNTER BIDEN AND OTHERS CASHED I
HUNTER BIDEN AND OTHERS CASHED N
HUNTER BIDEN AND OTHERS CASHED D
HUNTER BIDEN AND OTHERS CASHED S
HUNTER BIDEN AND OTHERS CASHED I
HUNTER BIDEN AND OTHERS CASHED E
HUNTER BIDEN AND OTHERS CASHED S
HUNTER BIDEN AND OTHERS CASHED I
HUNTER BIDEN AND OTHERS CASHED G
HUNTER BIDEN AND OTHERS CASHED Y
HAVING NO QUALIFICATIONS AND NO
EXPERIENCE.
IT NOW ABC APPARENTLY
INTERVIEWED HUNTER BIDEN AND WE
WILL FIND OUT MORE TOMORROW.
IT SHOULD BE INTERESTING A YEAR
WHAT HE HAS TO SAY.
LET'S SEE HOW HE DEALS WITH
QUESTIONS.
HOPEFULLY HE GETS THEM ABOUT
HAVING NO EXPERIENCE AND FLYING
OVER TO CHINA AND AIR FORCE TWO
AND TEN DAYS LATER BASICALLY
SAYING THE CHINESE BANK OF THE
BANK OF CHINA PICKED ME OVER
BANK CAPITAL, GOLDMAN SACHS,
DEUTSCHE BANK, THE REAL PROS AT
THIS.
IT LOOKS LIKE PANIC MAY BE
SETTING IN.
NOW IF YOU'RE PUTTING THE
BIDEN'S IN ALL-OUT DAMAGE
CONTROL AT THIS HOUR BECAUSE
HUNTER IS FINALLY BREAKING HIS
SIGNING.
I BET ANY AMOUNT OF MONEY IT'S
BEEN A LOT OF PREPARATION GOING
ON BEHIND THE SCENES.
I'M JUST GUESSING.
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IN HIS
BUSINESS, 31 OF THEM TELLS ME,
THAT PROBABLY HAVE INTEGRATED WE
WILL FIND ABOUT THAT IN TIME.
IN ADDITION TO SITTING DOWN FOR
AN INTERVIEW WITH "ABC NEWS," HE
ALSO ANNOUNCED HIS RESIGNATION
FROM A CHINESE PRIVATE EQUITY
COMPANY SAYING, THROUGH HIS
LAWYER, IF HIS FATHER BECOMES
PRESIDENT, HE WON'T SERVE ON ANY
FOREIGN BOARDS AT ALL.
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT LATE.
HE WAS DOING IT WHEN HIS FATHER
WAS VICE PRESIDENT.
IN COUNTRIES THAT HE WAS GOING
TO AND WORKING ON BEHALF OF THIS
COUNTRY FOR
WHAT IT DOESN'T ANSWER ANY OF
THE FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS, DOES
IT?
ABC IS GOING TO ASK SOME OF THE
BASIC FUNDAMENTAL QUESTIONS OR
GIVE HIM AN INTERVIEW.
I DON'T KNOW.
WELL THEY ASKED THE SPECIFICS OF
BIDEN'S WORK IN UKRAINE AND
CHINA?
WILL THEY ASK SPECIFICALLY WHAT
HE DID FOR ALL OF THIS MONEY?
WHAT WERE HIS ACTUAL DAY-TO-DAY
JOB DUTIES?
WILL THEY ASK WHAT
QUALIFICATIONS HE HAD?
WILL THEY ASK IF THE STATUS AS
THE SON OF AMERICA'S SECOND MOST
POWERFUL DECISION-MAKER WAS A
FACTOR IN A SWEETHEART DEAL?
WHY NOT PICK FAKE CAPITAL,
GOLDMAN SACHS, ANY OF THE BIG
FIRMS WITH TONS OF EXPERIENCE?
NOW IT'S ALSO PLAY OUR LITTLE
GAME.
LET'S REPLACE THE NAME VP
JOE BIDEN WITH VP DONALD TRUMP.
EVEN THOUGH THE PRESIDENT WOULD
NOT LIKE THAT DEMOTION.
WE WILL REPLACE THE NAME HUNTER
WITH THE NAME DON JR.
WHAT YOU THINK WOULD HAPPEN,
ESPECIALLY WITH THE MEDIA MOB?
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU'RE TAKING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM 100,
SHADY OILS DEALS, NO EXPERIENCE
IN THE COUNTRY, AND THEN
BILLIONS, A BILLION AND A HALF
TO BE EXACT, FROM THE BANK OF
CHINA AFTER FLYING WITH HIS
FATHER WHO WAS VICE PRESIDENT ON
AIR FORCE TWO WHEN DON JR. HAD
ZERO EXPERIENCE WITH ZERO
COUNTRY?
READILY, ZERO EXPERIENCE ANY ANY
BUSINESSES THAT ARE PAYING HIM.
YOU ACTUALLY THINK THE MOB AND
THE MEDIA WILL BE SAYING THIS IS
A CONSPIRACY THEORY OR A HOAX?
OR DO YOU THINK THEY ARE
ENDLESS, BREATHLESS HYSTERIA AND
REPORTING WOULD GO ON FOR MONTHS
AND MONTHS ON END?
ALSO DEVELOPING TONIGHT, THE
DEMOCRATS POLITICALLY MOTIVATED
UNCONSTITUTIONAL IMPEACHMENT
CHARADE IS UNRAVELING BEFORE
THEIR EYES AND EVEN ADAM, THE
COWARDLY ADAM SHIFTS IS BACK
TONIGHT MAKING A MAJOR ADMISSION
THAT MAY BE THE
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER WHO APPARENTLY
HIS TEAM COORDINATED WITH,
DOESN'T HAVE TO TESTIFY AT ALL.
AND HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN MORE
CLEAR ABOUT HIS SECRET CONTACT
IN HIS OFFICE IS CONTACT WITH
THE NONWHISTLE-BLOWER
WHISTLE-BLOWER IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
REPLACE SHIFT WITH THE NAME
TRUMP AND I WONDER IF THE MEDIA
WOULD ACCEPT THIS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE WERE INTERESTED IN HAVING
A WHISTLE-BLOWER COME FORWARD.
OR PRIMARY INTEREST RIGHT NOW IS
MAKING SURE THAT PERSON IS
PROTECTED.
NOW THERE'S MORE THAN ONE
WHISTLE-BLOWER THAT THEY ARE
PROTECTED AND GIVEN THAT WE
ALREADY HAVE THE CALL, IT MAY
NOT BE NECESSARY TO TAKE STEPS
THAT MIGHT REVEAL THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER'S IDENTITY TO DO
THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO MAKE SURE WE
PROTECT THAT.
>> Sean: I DOUBT THE MEDIA
WOULD GIVE TRUMP A PASS WITH
THAT FLIMSY ANSWER.
BY THE WAY, THE PRESIDENT JUST
WEIGHED IN, TWEETING, SHIFTY
SHIFT DOWN TEAMS TO THINK THEY
DON'T NEED THE WHISTLE-BLOWER
WHO STARTED THE WHOLE SCAM.
YET, BECAUSE THEY ARE GOING TO
FIND OUT ABOUT THE RELATIONSHIP,
WITH HIS OFFICE, AND THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
FACT THAT THEY DON'T NEED ANY
WHISTLE-BLOWER ANYWAY BECAUSE
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE THE
TRANSCRIPT.
MAYBE IT'S TIME FOR REPUBLICANS
IN THE SENATE AND THE HOUSE,
MAYBE THEY NEED TO GO ON RECORD
WITH THE VERY SIMPLE STATEMENT
THAT THAT TRANSCRIPT DOES NOT IN
ANY WAY RISE TO ANY LEVEL OF
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
LET'S GET THAT ON THE TABLE SO
THAT THEY CAN KNOW AHEAD OF TIME
THAT THIS WITCH HUNT IS NOT
GOING TO GO ON FOR THREE YEARS
LIKE THEIR LAST WITCH HUNT WENT
ON.
BY THE WAY, THE REAL REASON
WHISTLE-BLOWER HAS LOST ALL
CREDIBILITY WAS BECAUSE THE
STORY IS SO FAR FROM THE FACTS
OF THE ACTUAL TRANSCRIPT.
WE DON'T NEED THE INTERPRETATION
OF SOMEBODY THAT GOT THE
INFORMATION VIS-A-VIS HEARSAY.
ARE YOU STARTING TO NOTICE THE
THEME?
CORRUPTION, HYPOCRISY, LIES,
DECEIT IN THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
AND THEIR ALLIES IN THE MEDIA
MOB.
EVERY ACCUSATION THEY MAKE,
EVERY ATTACK, EVERY ALLEGATION,
IS NOTHING MORE THAN PROJECTION.
REMEMBER, SCHIFF SAID HE HAS NOT
SPOKEN DIRECTLY TO THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER WHEN IN FACT HIS
OFFICE DID HAVE DIRECT CONTACT
WITH THE INDIVIDUAL BEFORE HE
EVER FILED A COMPLAINT.
APPARENTLY HE WAS ADVISED BY
THAT TEAM TO GET A LAWYER.
TO FILE A COMPLAINT WITH THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
ANOTHER WORDS, THAT WOULD BE AN
ORGANIZED POLITICAL HIT JOB FROM
THE GET-GO.
AND ACCORDING TO THE
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER" TONIGHT,
WE ARE NOW LEARNING THE FAKE
WHISTLE-BLOWER HAS PROFESSIONAL
TIES TO JOE BIDEN.
SHOCKER.
DEMOCRATS ARE THE ONES GUILTY OF
REAL COLLUSION, CORRUPTION WITH
UKRAINE, THEY ARE THE ONES
GUILTY OF CONSPIRACY JUST LIKE
SCHIFF IS THE ONLY ONE THAT I
KNOW ON TAPE THINKING HE IS
SPEAKING TO A RUSSIAN, DIGGING
UP DIRT ON DONALD TRUMP AND OF
COURSE, COMPROMISING MATERIALS
AND ALL OF THAT.
AND OF COURSE VLADIMIR KNOWS.
THEN, TOO, LEVERAGING TAX
DOLLARS AND A QUID PRO QUO.
AN OBVIOUS SHAKE DOWN WITH OUR
MONEY TO FIRE A PROSECUTOR IN
UKRAINE AND IT LITERALLY WORKING
IN UKRAINE, ACCORDING TO
POLITICO, JANUARY 11TH 2017, HE
HAD THE UKRAINIANS WORKING ON
HILLARY'S BEHALF FOR THAT
ELECTION AND THEY SCREWED UP.
THEY PICKED THE WRONG HORSE.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT
WEAPONIZED INTELLIGENCE TO SPY
ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT USED
RUSSIAN LINES TO INFLUENCE THE
2016 ELECTION AND THEN TO SPY ON
A CANDIDATE AND A TRANSITION
TEAM AND THEN LATER A PRESIDENT.
BY THE WAY, THAT'S THAT.
HERE WAS A REACTION, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTER, SARA CARTER.
ALL RIGHT, YOU LOOKED AT IT
THAT'S ALL, IT'S NOT LIKE
BOOMERANGS EVERYWHERE.
IT ALL COMES BACK TO THEM.
BUT IT'S TRUE, IF YOU REPLACE
THE NAME TRUMP WITH BIDEN, I
THINK WE GET A VERY DIFFERENT
REACTION FROM THE CORRUPT MEDIA.
STICK A WALL, THEY WOULD BE
DRAGGED THROUGH THE MUD THE WAY
THEY WERE ALREADY BEING DRAGGED
THROUGH THE MUD ON FALSE
STORIES.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS SEE HOW
THE EVIDENCE IS POURING OUT
AGAINST THEM.
THE BOOMERANG, AS YOU SAY.
IT WASN'T ONLY THAT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER STORY DIDN'T JUST
ADD UP, ADAM SCHIFF AND THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER HIMSELF DID NOT
INFORM THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY IS AN
INSPECTOR GENERAL MICHAEL
ADKINSON THAT THEY HAD
COMMUNICATED, THAT HE BASICALLY
WAS IN COMMUNICATION WITH
ADAM SCHIFF COMMITTEE ON THIS
AND WILL REQUESTED HELP FROM THE
COMMITTEE BEFORE SUBMITTING THE
COMPLAINT.
NOW WE FIND OUT THAT OF COURSE,
LO AND BEHOLD, THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER WORKED FOR
JOE BIDEN IN THE PAST AND THAT
THEY DID ADMIT TO THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL, THAT THEY DID
WORK FOR A PROMINENT DEMOCRAT,
THEY DID KNOW THAT.
SO WHAT WE ARE SEEING HERE IS A
CONTINUOUS COVER-UP.
THIS IS THE REASON WHY
ADAM SCHIFF DOESN'T WANT THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER ACTUALLY TO COME
FORWARD.
HE WANTS TO PUSH THIS ASIDE NOW.
WE KNOW THERE WAS NO QUID PRO
QUO.
THERE WAS ABSOLUTELY NO QUID PRO
QUO BECAUSE WE KNOW NOW FROM
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY OF UKRAINE
AND THAT HE HAD NO IDEA THAT ANY
MILITARY AID WAS BEING WITHHELD.
BUYER TO SPEAKING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND EVEN AFTER.
HE JUST HAD NO IDEA AND IF YOU
LOOK AT THE TRANSCRIPT ON ITS
FACE, WHICH WAS EVENTUALLY
RELEASED BY THE PRESIDENT, YOU
CAN SEE THAT FOR YOURSELF.
SO NOW, OF COURSE, SCHIFF IS
TRYING TO FIND A WAY TO COVER UP
FOR THIS, BUT REMEMBER THIS.
THIS IS SOMETHING I'VE BEEN
TALKING TO SOURCES ON
CAPITOL HILL ABOUT.
SCHIFF IS CONTINUING TO PUSH
OVER AND OVER AGAIN FOR SOME
TYPE OF IMPEACHMENT AND THIS IS
MOVING FORWARD AS AN IMPEACHMENT
INVESTIGATION.
I JUST DON'T THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO BUY THESE
LIES ANYMORE.
>> Sean: I WILL TELL YOU, IF
THEY DO, WE WILL LOSE THIS GREAT